we have him
no
he hasn't in every great action film
there are major stunt sequences to pull
off costumes that could spontaneously
combust and dangerous scenes performed
in freezing cold waters prey has all of
that and more in this action-packed
predator sequel
the predator costume was the cause of
some pretty major challenges for actor
dane delegro the cast talked with cinema
blend about the filming process and dane
expressed how excited he was to see the
movie because while he was filming in
the suit he couldn't see or hear
anything at all when predator's head was
facing forward dane's head was looking
down at the ground through two tiny
slits in the neck the only way he was
able to get through the fight scenes was
by following sticks on the ground and
listening to cues through a buzzing
earpiece i can't wait to see this thing
i didn't see a damn thing
number two yeah the predator suit also
went up in flames for a minute there in
the scene where raphael is trying to
hide from predator but ends up being
found and brutally eliminated dane
irritated some of the wires in his suit
while lifting his arm up to do the
slashing motion when he was walking back
to his reset mark he heard rich cohen
who talks to him through the speaker in
his ear
unfortunately he short-circuited the
battery pack right above his shoulder
doing too many takes
luckily the crew was able to get
everything off in time for him to leave
with little to no injuries number three
we've got a lot to say about the
predator suit first in discussion though
is the fact that there were six
different suits each one had their own
particular scent to it apparently that
foam latex really held onto every drop
of sweat and the scents that came along
with it after each day there'd be a team
of people wringing them out oh man they
still got the goop on you and he's like
that's not goop that's my sweat clearly
daned allegro and his suits went through
the ringer on this film there's
instances where i would squat down in my
knees and sweat would kind of shoot out
of my
zeus number four yeah no one had a good
time getting down and dirty in that
thing
the mud pit
um smelled like rotting fertilizer poo
the weird part about it is that it
actually smelled fine before they got
into it it was only after it was touched
by human flesh that it started to get
the awful smell think of a raw sewage
and then multiply that by ten and then
you have a fraction of what it's like
number five they can't catch a break
from this mud not only was it brutal
getting into the pit but it was also a
huge ordeal to clean up afterward in an
interview with bloody disgusting amber
midhunter opens up about what she went
through after leaving the pit i would
get out of that and walk over to a dark
tent with a horse trough i would stand
there and four women would hose me down
they were so sweet and lovely they gave
me hot water because it was also cold
that was a wild experience when i think
of the details
number six we're talking tons and tons
of smoke but barely anything getting
captured the crew had four machines on
the back of pickup trucks just churning
out massive amounts of smoke for the
burnt glade sequence there was so much
in fact that there were helicopters
coming out to make sure it wasn't a
brush fire the painful part of this for
dan trachtenberg was that over the
course of eight days they had to shoot
this they just couldn't get it done
because the smoke wouldn't stay in the
air at lunch i was just kind of had a
little bit of
a freak out and was like well we have to
rewrite the scene they ended up slowly
getting one shot at a time and putting
it all together but it was a longer much
more grueling process than it was
expected to be number seven we're going
back to the burnt glade sequence again
dakota beavers as a first time actor
really struggled with trying to get this
done on little to no sleep you know you
get a little
a little crazy when you haven't slept
right not only were the fans blowing
smoke in his and amber's faces as they
were trying to film but they also
couldn't hear each other and needed
earpieces
number eight dakota beavers wanted to do
as many stunts as they would let him so
badly that he didn't want anyone to know
he'd been injured because he didn't want
to be taken off the stunt when i'm
rolling in the in the dirt uh i'm not
wearing a shirt so i was just covered
with scratches there's another scene
where he's laying horizontally on the
ground and he pulled a muscle in his
abdomen pretty badly so that was
actually really painful but i didn't
tell anybody number nine there was a bit
of fear on set while filming in these
mountains around the time of the shoot
that's when all the bears were coming
out of hibernation in canada so there
needed to be a bear guard on set at all
times in case any bears approached the
set the bears were waking up and they
were hungry so we had to like kind of be
careful number 10 it was a grueling four
weeks amber midhunter and the rest of
the cast were given a mandatory boot
camp to prepare for their roles we did
weapons and we had a personal trainer
and the some people were there even with
all the training there were still plenty
of scenes that they couldn't have
imagined would be as difficult as they
are there's some level of just no
ability to prepare for some of the
things that we were doing number 11.
this seems to be a theme when it came to
the struggle of getting this movie done
amber midhunter found herself getting
completely disoriented when it came to
reshooting scenes for the sake of
getting the best flight
they'd be halfway through one scene and
then they'd tell her oh you have to go
back here oh makeup change something
something you're gonna be on the cliff i
was like what is going on because of all
these random scenes resets she
completely lost all concept of time oh
my god you're never gonna believe i'm
not gonna survive number 12 amber also
had to learn a ton of choreography for
this film she actually wishes it didn't
take as long as it did in my world i
remember that fight as a magical thing
that i learned yeah it definitely wasn't
that simple over like three days and
there was no rehearsal every free moment
she had she would get pulled into more
rehearsal to learn major fight sequences
we changed it a lot at the last minute
and you did have to learn that very
quickly in your defense number 13.
obviously there are a ton of stunts in
this film and some hard-working stunt
doubles to do them but amber like dakota
beavers wanted to do as many stunts as
they would let her she talks to slash
film about the kind of stunts she had to
perform as naaru i would learn every
stunt sequence in its entirety and as
much as i could possibly do i wanted to
do everything myself so i got to jump
off the tree i got to get thrown off of
the predator i got to fight him because
of this she even had input on how major
fight sequences would play out
dan would kind of guide the stun team
and then the stunt team would take it to
me
number 14. this was amber's most
daunting scene due to the fact it was
performed in an actual freezing cold
river though it was summertime the scene
was filmed in a glacial runoff she was
basically starting off her day with an
ice bath for five days straight though
it ended up being one of her most
rewarding scenes to pull off every day
she would just stare at the river full
of anxiety before she had to get in it
number 15. coco the shelter dog lands
the role of a lifetime as sorry naru's
fluffy sidekick yeah the dog was chaos
though everyone loved her as a companion
sometimes the set proved to be a bit
challenging for her there was a moment
during filming where producer jane myers
was trying to help everyone with their
war cry and well dog just like took off
and it had been headed for the hills the
dog trainer was not very happy with her
the doctor just looked at me he got so
mad at me that scared the dog even after
costumes being lit aflame intense boot
camps ice cold water and painful stunt
choreography this cast and crew wouldn't
have wanted prey to go any other way
what was your favorite moment from the
film